de
bundan Yaklaşık dört yıl öncesinde
arkadaşlar da bir masada otururken
aramızda şöyle bir konuşma geçmişti
bir gün mücadele nitelikli konuşması
önce olarak anlatacaksın demişlerdi o
gün bugünmüş de bugün Ben çok
heyecanlıyım
Herkesin bir hayali vardır Bu ile
getirmeye korktuğu ya sanki dile getirse
o hayali nefsini bozulacak
gerçekleşmeyecek diye düşündü
Benim de çocukluktan beri bu ev sonu
hayalim Doktor olmaktı
Ancak ben bu Bu kurduğumda on yaşında ve
henüz okula gitmeyen bir kız çocuğuydu
elim penceresinden arkadaşlarımın
okuldan dönüşüne heyecanla beklerdim
onların okul anılarını büyük bir meraklı
dinledim
benim bu kadar hevesli olmam nedeniyle
içinde bana küçük sınıf oluşturulmuş
tıbbi babam defter alırdı kitap alırdı
Ablalarım da benimle ilgilenir okuma
yazma öğretimi verdi ama benim istediğim
şey çok farklıydı arkadaşlarım gibi bi
tenefüste arkadaşlarımla oynamak mutlaka
parmak kaldırmak ödevlerim eve gelince
de ertesi günü yetiştirmeye çalışmak
gibi heveslerin vardı
bu Hevesimi ailem kayıtsız kalamadı
bulunduğumuz ilçenin fiziksel koşulları
engelleri Uygun olmadığı için ve böyle
bir okul bulunmadığı için farklı bir
ülkeye taşındık o ilçede in fiziksel bu
engelleri için oluşturulmuş bir ilkokul
vardı Böyle Ben 10 yaşında
yıkama takıp mavi önemi giyip ilkokula
başladım tam Hayallerim gibiydi tahtaya
çıkıp soru çözüyor dum teneffüs
aralarında arkadaşlarımı kovalamaca
oynuyordum tekerlekli sandalye ve
Saklambaç alıyordum özgüvenimin
yerleştiği yıllar o yıllar diyebilirim
ilk okul
bitip hayatının ikinci dönüm noktası
lise sınavı
belli tercih
listede lise sınavında ilgili puan
almıştım
ancak artık gideceğim okul tırnak içinde
normal bir okuldu ne demek fiziksel
koşulları engelli için uygun olmayan bir
okul ve okul daha öncesinde hiç engelli
öğrenci
evi kazanmamış ve engel Az önce okumamış
iştah Nadir sizi çok fazla yani şey
dedim çok fazla korkuyordum
bu endişe malzeme gözünden kaçmadı Annem
ve babam bir gün beni karşılarına alıp
öyle söylediler
birisi kazanmış olabilirsiniz ancak
gitmeyede bilirsin çünkü gittiğinde ben
önyargılarla karşılaşabilirsin yalnız
kalabilirsin yer arkadaşları tarafından
yadırganan bilirsin
üzülebilirsin
orada şöyle söyledim ben arkadaş için
değil Hayallerim için gidiyorum dedim
şimdi verdiğim en doğru kararlardan biri
kimse
tahmin ettikleri gibi oldu aslında ilk
bir yıl tamamen Yalnızdım Sabah sınıfa
girerdim trama geçerdim akşam O sıradan
kalkıp evime giderdim
tenefüste çıkmazdım öyle yemeklerini
yalnız yerdim bu arkadaşlarla geç
konuşmazlık diyebilirim
iletişim minimal deydi
zamanda onlar beni ben onları anladım
Çünkü onlar benden çekiniyorlar
dışarıya olabileceğini düşünüyorlardı
Zamanla birbirimizi ne şakalar yapmaya
başladık birbirinizle alay ettik
birlikte okula stajyerlere kaçtık
sınavlarda birlikte yardımlaşma
sıktı ve Dört yılın sonunda şu an bile
hatırladığımda yüzünde kocaman gülümseme
oluşan bir süre alım oldu
birçok ama yaşadım bunlardan bir tanesi
mesela
sınıfta laboratuvarlar üst kattaydı
bizim sınıfımız al sınıflarda alt
kattaydı
Bir sınıftaki erkek arkadaşlar beni her
zaman laboratuvar dersin üst katını atıp
üst kata bu ve o sırada da akülü
sandalye yeterince aşk üzerine bir de
ben alırım ancak arkadaşlarla Çıktığım
zaman zorlandıklarını farkındayım bana
şöyle söylerlerdi çok hafifsin Hayır çok
güzel çok ki de güzel hep çıkalım Keşke
dersimiz kaplı olsa da hep bu kütlesi
çok güzel günlerdi ve
liseden mezun olduğunda
birincilik konuşmasını yapmak için
kürsüye çıktığında arkadaşlarıma
teşekkür etme fırsatım oldu
ayarla bir adım daha yaklaştım
üniversite sınavı
üniversite sınavından yüksek bir puan
almıştım ve Tıp Fakültesi'ni kazanan
biliyordum ama bu kadar kolay olmadı
kim tercihimi sorduğunda herhangi bir
tercih mi sorduğunda
Doktor olmak istediğime Tıp Fakültesi'ni
tercih ettiğimi söylediğimde hep aynı
benzerken nelerle karşılaştı iki
tekerlekli sandalye Anneme ne her zaman
nasıl hastaneye gideceksin nöbetleri
nasıl tutacaksın
Bunlar benim kafamda kocaman soru
işaretiyle tabii ki
o tercih döneminde
sabahlara kadar araştırma Yaptım sanırım
tekerlekli sandalyesiyle tıp fakültesine
başlayıp bitiren biri var mı aynı
fakültenin eğitimini nasıl hangi
Laboratuvar nasıl
günlerce araştırdım
lisede Okul müdürümüz tercih döneminde
beni yanına çağırmıştı tercihi sordum da
aynı şekilde Tıp Fakültesi'ni tercih
etmek istediğim ama çok korktuğumu Belki
de tercih edilmeye bileceğim söyledim
onu şu yok şu cümleyi söyledi
bi Evet fare şimdiye kadar kimse
tekerlekli sandalyesiyle tıp fakültesine
Gitmemiş olabilir giderek Bu yolu
seçebilirsin diğer insanları sen cesaret
verebilirsin en
son şunu düşündüm Neden olmasın
sonrasında Tıp Fakültesi tercihlerimi
yaptım sonuçları açıklandı evde bir
bayram havası
ancak fare çok mutlu değil düşünüyorum
neler yaşayacağım yine yalnız mı
kalacağım ne olacak yadırganacak mıyım
arkadaş
bakımından gittiniz kalmadım diyebilirim
Çok şanslıydım
Ancak
geçen o altı yıl
hocam an kalp kırıklarıyla doluydu oldu
daha önce bir uygarlıkları gibi ben çok
yoruldum çok zorlandım çok
düştümde her defasında daha güçlü
kalktım ama asla pişman olmadım
tahmin ettikleri nedenlerden dolayı
yorulmadım ya da zorlanmadım Beni yoran
zorlayan kalp kırıklarına neden olan tek
şey de o yerdeki engelli yapabilir mi
ağrısıydı
herhangi küçük bir sorunla sıradan bir
soruna
gerekli yerlere gittiğimde fakülte
içinde
çok ince cümlelerle karşılaştım ve
gelecekte meslektaş olacağım
kişiler tarafından bunları duymak
sanırım hala
düşündüğümde bile beni üzülen taraf
alırım Her seferinde şu söylendi engelli
olduğunu biliyordum neden Tıp
Fakültesi'ni tercih ettim Bunları kabul
edeceksin asla gittim sorun engellilik
durumu ile ilgili fiziksel durumundaki
ilgili ilgisi olmasa dahi bu cümlelerle
karşılaştık
gaza pes etmedim
çok şey öğrendim mesela yalnız geceler
kalabilmeyi öğrendim yemeklerde
çekyat açıp ya da bir kal bu gören dim
araba kullanmayı öğrendim daha kolay
kolay hastaneye gideceğim Gidip
gelebilmek için
en çok da annemin neler yaşadığını
öğrendim Beni büyütürken
bununla ilgili şöyle bir anından
bahsetmek istiyorum
Bilgin asansör
değil kadınla karşılaştım kadın beni
görünce çok heyecanlandı
bizde
Pediatri bölümünde şu oda numarasında
yapıyoruz kızımla gibi ziyarete gelmek
ister misiniz Doktor hanım dedi
doktor olduğunu bilmesi ilginç geldi
aynı zamanda bir de merak uyandın için
beni odasına davet ediyorum için ısrarla
gelmemi istiyor heyecanlı Neden ben
odaya gittim şeyim yatarsa güzeller
güzeli bir kız çocuğu
8-9 aylık kipine biraz yani omurilik
açıklığı var
yürüyemeyecek puanla
bu oynayacağını daha sonra anne bebeği
ile fotoğraf çekildim istedik ve bana
şöyle söyledi
Ben Zeynep de hamileyken
ben Ailem çok istemedi ultrasonda
engelli olduğunu duydukları için
aldırmam yanında çok ısrar ettiler Ancak
ben Zeynep'e kıyamadım
şu an ileride bir sıkıntı olduğunda o
fotoğrafı göstereceğim Zeynep bu doktor
ablası gibi olabilir diyeceğim demişti
ay şöyle düşündüm Evet o yola ilk defa
ben çıktım Ama benden sonra gelecekler
için motor oğlum annem neler Annem neler
yaşamış Onu anladım bir kez daha aile
minnettar ol
altı yıl boyunca çok şey öğrendim
ve öğrendiğim en önemli şeylerden biri
Ne oldu
artık bazı şeyleri cümleye dökmeden
anlaşılabiliyor
dumbak ülkede çeken geldi ben olduğum
için birçok yere rampa yapmak için çok
mücadele verdik arkadaşlarımla
bunlardan bir tanesi
şekilde oldu
paketini kafeteryası normalde çok
kalabalık olur
bu gittiğimizde masalarda boş yer
bulamayız
mezuniyetine son altı ay kala Pakize
kafeteryasında gidiyorum ve bomboş
kimseler yok bu dayanamadım kaç gün
sonra görevliye sordum niçin kafeterya
bu kadar boş dedim bilmiyor musun Neden
Ey dedim fakülte öğrencileri kantini
protesto diyor dedin için dedim
Tarık
kantinden terasa geçen bir yer var böyle
34 Hadi basamak var orada RAM var ama
altı yıl boyunca o kadar şeyle mücadele
ettim ki o terasa çıkıp bir kahve içmek
asla aklımdan geçmedi
orada rampa olmadığı için fakültedeki
arkadaşlar protez geliyormuş ben
mezuniyeti altı ay kala oraya rampa
yapıldı
şu an bile
söylerken çok duygulanıyorum
Çünkü şunu anladım ben bu yola çıktım
ama bu yolda yalnız yürümüyorum
altı yıl sonrasında
bu Fakültesinden birlikte Mezun oldu
o kürsüye çıktım bir filmin gala gecesi
gibiydi
yaşadığım tüm sıkıntılar tüm zorlanmalar
tüm kırgınlıklar o sahnede güle gel aynı
zamanda teşekkür etmem gereken birçok
kişi vardı
O çok hocam tarafından çok güzel destek
almıştım beni her gördüklerinde çok iyi
hekim olacağını söylerlerdi Ben
yürütülür eklenir lerdi
fakültedeki arkadaşlarım Sadece rampa
konusunda değil ders notları konusunda
bile bile kırtasiyeden benim adıma ders
notları Çıkarım her sabah masamızın ne
koyarsak artık
o gün ailem de oradaydı arkadaşlarım da
oradaydı Beni inciten kalbimi kıran
insanlar oradaydı bir filmin gala gecesi
gibiydi ve çok güzeldi hayatımın en
güzel günlerinden biriydi sanırım
sonra kedi Burak'ı sanki en yüksek bir
fırlatma gerekiyormuş bütün tüm
Sıkıntılarım roketi hava yapıyor muşum
gibi hissettim
başardım dedim bitti
gitmemiş
mezun olduktan Allah
herkesin bildiği Tıpta Uzmanlık sınavı
TUS
barbarorum sınav herkesin bildiği gibi
iyi bir puan al
istediğin çoğu benim tutuyordu geliyordu
tercih etmek istedim herkes gibi birkaç
branş var
Ve bunun içinde bazı kişilere görüş
sormam gerekiyor nasıldır nöbeti Nasıldı
iş yoğunluğu nasıldır çalışma ortamı
nasıldır
ben gittiğimde yine meslektaşım olacak
kişiler tarafından o kadar ince Sildim
ki
bu cümleyi duydum mesela Tıp
Fakültesi'ni yazarak zaten bir hata
yapmışsın Piri klinik temel bilim yaz
hasta görme zorlanma Ama sen bu bölümü
yazma neden engellesin bu böyle
kalmayacak şu an hevesli sınama bundan
Birkaç yıl sonrasına çok ne yapacaksın
nasıl gelip gideceksin
sanki alt yıl boyunca
bu nasıl okuduğunu bunu ya da bilmiyorum
Bir pozitif ayrımcılık olduğunu
düşündüler sanırım
çok incindim o önyargı duvarları sürekli
sürekli sürekli önüme çıktı
bu vazgeçmedim Ama
şu anda çok
sevdiğimi mal anda psikiyatri alanında
uzmanlık eğitimi devam ediyorum
çalıştığım insanlarla sok mutluyum
hocalarım çok seviyorum
Doktor olmaya çok seviyorum
Çok mutluyum şu Bu sadece benim bir
hayalini gerçekleştirirken yaşadım
mücadele bir kısmıydı ancak mücadelen
bitmedi devam ediyor
bu devam ediyor bazen düşüyorum
daha güçlü kalkıyorum bazen engebeler
çıkıyor kenara geçip biraz dinleniyorum
Arkama dönüp bakıyorum aldığım yolu
görüyorum benimle birlikte yola çıkan
insanları görüyorum yol devam ediyor ve
ben bu yolda çok mutluyum
Teşekkürler canım